voici comme villa mon style
jenny sincèrement tu ressens la place
david bowie jade c'est gentil risque
devrait être maquiller le visage se
laisser pousser les cheveux et le
problème c'est que si je me maquille
vais ressembler à dalida donc
alors être petit débrief de la semaine
dernière thierry bas sur internet les
twittos son était très virulent avec
vous parce que vous avez beaucoup
critiqué françois hollande là
franchement je vous soutiens pas non
mais c'est vrai non mais ça se fait pas
il nous a prouvé quand même qu'ils
étaient capables qu'ils étaient capables
qui était capable de bien porter les
fleurs qui jouait très bien la tristesse
voilà si jamais en 2017 françois
hollande y ait pas réélu on sait qui il
pourra bosser chez interflora ou
cherokee tenir tout simplement
qu'au mali jol on va pas faire les
mythos à tulle a fait pendant deux ans
au grand journal qui sait mieux que
personne ce que je suis en train de
vivre ça je peux te dire venir faire des
vanneaux aux invités qui font la gueule
souvent on
l'a vu la semaine dernière à cracher des
bâtiments en même temps c'était pas
évident de savoir quand on était content
en tout cas elle faisait la gueule tu as
commencé par le jamel comedy club
fabrice éboué c'est quand même vous qui
vous en êtes où le mieux sorti très
sincèrement tu crois que claudia tagbo
ça m'a fait marrer de faire le décor
pencher nature
faut bien bouffer c'est normal
en tout cas thomas ngijol aujourd'hui on
sent que c'est un homme plus mûr plus
posée c'est vrai alors je ne sais pas si
c'est le fait d'être d'être papa ou
d'être blindés mais on sent que il est
bien dans sa tête non mais c'est vrai
mais thomas c'est aussi le cinéma cas ce
départ le crocodile du boat song a fast
life nord dedans il joue un un esclave
un dictateur africain champion
d'athlétisme
bravo les clichés que des rôles de noirs
et le pire c'est que c'est lui qui écrit
ses films donc tout simplement voilà le
prochain film si tu joues en éboueurs je
te jure je t'envoie sos racisme occupent
tout simplement
michèle bernier michel vous avez fait
vos premiers pas avec mimie mathy et
isabelle de botton 1 dans le petit
théâtre de bouvard pour les plus jeunes
qui nous regardent le petit théâtre de
bouvard c'était un peu le lancer du
jamel comedy club voilà donc tu sais ce
que ça veut dire thomas peut-être que
dans 20 ans toi aussi tu joueras un
enjeu qui claque des doigts sur tf1 mais
non mais c'est au petit pois c'est au
titane de vous voir vous allez
rencontrer la gloire et puis aussi le
papa de vos enfants bruno gaccio c'est
vrai que c'est souvent sur le lieu de
travail qu'on rencontre l'amour 1 c'est
me regardez pas comme ça je regardais
pas comme ça demain en plus je déteste
et mon chéri que vous m'avez livre est
franchement
jacques attali a voilà le plus déconneur
des trois ce soir jacques tu lui laisse
la parole cinq minutes il te sort
connerie sur connerie non mais c'est
vrai patrick sébastien côté c'est un
petit chanteur à la croix de bois
polytechnique école des mines sciences
po l'ena tout ça pour finir la plupart
du temps sur bfmtv c'est cool
jacques alors ça à chaque fois que vous
êtes invitée sur un plateau t on vous
demande de faire des prédictions des
économistes que vous auriez dû le faire
c'est voyante jack klues fils je prévois
des boucles d'oreilles un jeu de tarot
une caravane au bois de boulogne et puis
voilà vous aurez gagné plus d'argent
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
posez michèle bernier alors plus jeune
vous avez démarré jeudi avec avec mimie
mathy ça vous fait quoi qu'aujourd'hui
ça soit elle qui vous regardent de haut
thierry franchement
m
thomas n'gijol art votre compagne karole
rocher c'est aussi votre metteur en
scène est-ce que du coup vous arrivez à
faire la différence quand vous coucher
pour le plaisir ou couché pour le boulot
car du michel dans son livre coucher
pour réussir dans ma confiance en lui
[Rires]
et pour terminer jacques attali vous
avez un frère jumeau bernard attali mais
contrairement aux frères bogdanoff vous
avez décidé de ne pas faire carrière
avec lui il est si moche que ça
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux